NEXT, GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
A >> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING
AND WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE SPENT AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT AND EXPLAIN WHAT’S
HAPPENING TO OUR COUNTRY.
AT TIMES IT’S BEEN DEPRESSING
BUT IT SEEMS IMPORTANT.
AT THIS POINT IT SEEMS PRETTY
CLEAR THAT NOTHING IS WHAT WE
ARE TOLD IT IS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT PROTESTS, IT’S
NOT ABOUT GEORGE FLOYD OR
SYSTEMIC RACISM, AMERICA IS NOT
A RACIST COUNTRY.
YOU ARE NOT A BAD PERSON FOR
LIVING HERE.
THESE ARE DEFINITELY NOT
PROTESTERS AND THEY ARE NOT
WRITERS.
THEY ARE WORKING TO OVERTHROW
THE GOVERNMENT AND TRYING TO PUT
THEMSELVES IN POWER.
BUT IN THE PROCESS OF SAYING
THAT, WE MAY HAVE MISSED
SOMETHING ELSE THAT IS ALSO TRUE
AS WELL AS HIGHLY AMUSING.
THESE PEOPLE ARE IDIOTS, FOR
REAL.
THE ANGRY CHILDREN THAT YOU
WATCHED SET FIRE TO WENDY’S AND
TOPPLE STATUES AND SCREAM AT YOU
ON TELEVISION DAY AFTER DAY ARE
TRULY AND UTTERLY STUPID.
THIS PROBABLY NEVER BEEN A
DUMBER GROUP GATHERED IN ONE
PLACE AND ALL OF AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THEY ARE MOUTH BREATHER’S.
THEY KNOW NOTHING.
THEY COULDN’T TELL YOU WHO
GEORGE WASHINGTON WAS.
THEY SAY THEY OPPOSE RACISM AND
THEY RIP DOWN MONUMENTS TO FOUR
ABOLITIONISTS.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHO THE
ABOLITIONISTS WERE.
I THINK IT’S A BAND FOR THE
80s.
THE STUPIDEST PEOPLE ARE "WELL
EDUCATED.
AND THEY HOLD A GOOD PAYING JOB
AT DIGITAL.
THEY ARE SUPPOSEDLY IMPRESSIVE
BUT THEY ARE NOT IMPRESSIVE AT
ALL.
THEY FALL FOR ANY LIE NO MATTER
HOW PREPOSTEROUS, THE MORE
PREPOSTEROUS THE MORE LIKELY
THEY ARE TO FALL FOR IT.
AND LIKE SMALL CHILDREN THEY ARE
AFRAID OF EVERYTHING.
IN CALIFORNIA HISPANIC UTILITY
WORKER MADE THE MISTAKE OF
CRACKING HIS KNUCKLES AT A
RED LIGHT.
THE GENIUSES THOUGHT HE WAS
FLASHING A WHITE SUPREMACIST
GANG SIGN SO THEY FIRED ON HIM.
IN OAKLAND, LIBBY SCHAAF CLAIMS
SHE WENT TO COLLEGE AND LAW
SCHOOL, SHE MISTOOK EXERCISE
EQUIPMENT IN A PARK FOR
KU KLUX KLAN NOOSES.
THEN THERE WAS A PRESS
CONFERENCE ABOUT HATE CRIMES.
TALK ABOUT TEXTBOOK HYSTERIA,
BUT IT WAS ALSO HYSTERICALLY
FUNNY.
FOR PEOPLE COME UP THIS NEUROTIC
LIFE IS ONE LONG HORROR MOVIE.
THEY SQUIRM IN THEIR SEATS
PARALYZED BY FEAR.
THEY ARE TOO AFRAID, AND THAT’S
JUST LIKE THIS, SYMPATHETICALLY.
THIS GROUP LIVES IN THE AFFLUENT
PARK OF MINNEAPOLIS.
CALLING THE POLICE THEY DECIDED
WAS A RACIST.
SO THEY DIDN’T CALL POLICE.
ALMOST INFINITELY HUNDREDS OF
MENTALLY ILL HOMELESS DRUG
ADDICTS SHOWED UP AND ERECTED A
TENT PARK.
AND PEOPLE OVERDOSED.
AND THEY FOUND THEMSELVES
CORNERED BY TWO THUGS PUT A GUN
INTO HIS STOMACH AND DEMANDED
HIS CAR KEYS.
SO FINALLY BROKE DOWN AND CALLED
POLICE.
APPARENTLY NOT JOKING.
CAN PEOPLE THIS DAMAGED AND THIS
WEEK ACTUALLY RUN A COUNTRY?
THE ANSWER IS NO, OF COURSE NOT.
AND WE DEFINITELY SHOULD NOT LET
THEM.
IN THE MEANTIME WE ALSO SHOULD